[Music]
born
in 1966
he turned his life around
he wasn't doing so hot
he got rid of that weight
and he gained a lot of wisdom
[Music]
he lives in a tent
[Applause]
thank you all so much
for playing along
and i hope you have a wonderful night
and i'd like to welcome to the stage
mr
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to roll on where
after a few
minutes off a non-voluntary covet
induced free speech impinging mini
sabbatical the boys are finally back
and once again in the seat across from
me we find the hooch to my turner
the isles to my rizzoli the mertog to my
rigs the chef to my chef inside joke for
all you fans of the bear we're going to
get into that later
uh the literary line himself mr adam
skolnik and today as is our want we
bring a fresh perspective on sports art
culture world events try to make a
little more sense of this insane world
we all inhabit and have a few laughs
along the way so
today we got a bit of catching up to do
because how many weeks has it been since
we've done this
i feel rusty yeah you feel rusty i do
when's the last time you were in the
that that captain's seat you mean doing
a podcast yeah oh last week
oh just not with you i'm rusty with you
we have to we feel like you're right our
relationship has to get insane it's
gonna be like you know a couple that has
like
we haven't talked in a bit yeah
you know right and then the first time
back it's like you know
but i think we're doing okay i think
we'll hit our strides so yeah today we
got some interesting stories from
the world of athletics and ultra running
as usual we share a few things we've
been enjoying respectively
uh based on the outline in front of me
which i'm willing to toss out the window
and just free will if you want uh but
i'd characterize what we've kind of
thought about talking about today as as
a as a pretty
classic
version of roll on an old school roll-on
if it can be old school yeah a a retro
a retro on have we've been doing it long
enough that we can do vintage
it's a vintage roll on it's let's see
let's see if we'll see what the
listening public has to do now anyway
they were concerned i was getting
messages saying where's roll on are you
did something happen did you are you
guys in a fight is that the did you
stoke that that theory that conspiracy
theory i
i sprinkled it i i have a reddit thread
i didn't tweet out that i had covid and
we were gonna have to take a break right
um but you know not everyone's on
twitter so well i mean i think we should
one thing we should dispense with before
we get into the atom check-in mm-hmm
tell me tell us how you're feeling
covered for the second time and what six
weeks why don't you check in first and
we'll get into it okay i'm happy to
share about it all right
well i'm excited to announce my new
career
i've tendered my resignation at ben and
jerry's is that is that shirt part of
the uniform for whatever this new career
is no it's just a shirt
but that might be the most skull nikki
and shirt i've ever seen you wear there
you go it's a skolnickian by way of
patagonia
but i've been spending the last several
weeks while um when you haven't been
nurturing my calls
just really connected to the la
sheriff's department where i've been
training as a driver's license revocator
and so what that means is i've been
deputized with the power
that if you flout the rules of the road
in front of me
i can and will revoke your license on
the spot so that means if you cut me off
by changing lanes or turning late onto
the road right in front of me and then
immediately hit your brakes
by the time you get home you will no
longer be a licensed driver
are you feeling disempowered in your
life no i'm just serious where is this
impulse coming if you run a four-way
stop while i'm running while pushing a
stroller
no more license for you that's where
this comes from right so i'm just trying
to play this out like the practicalities
of it so you're going to chase this guy
down and potentially get into a physical
altercation no no i just get that
license number the license plate and
then we do we work all the little ring
cameras there's an algorithm that i work
all the ring cameras i can find all the
public cameras we get the driver's face
recognition
and immediately i can do it virtually
that's how good i am that's how that's
this training is all about how much time
have you invested in this fantasy
fantasy this is a real thing
if i see you creeping along the road at
rush hour traffic with a long line of
cars behind you and you're looking for a
parking space for you
i will issue a warning and and if it
doesn't happen again what are you
supposed to do if you're looking for a
parking spot listen i'm tough but fair
you need to you need to slow down to
find that spot i know but there's ways
of doing it rich you know we're in this
together we're this is a this is a team
game well i might need to deploy your
services because uh my eldest daughter
mathis she just got her
driver's license and she's been driving
around for all of ten day ten days at
this point as a newly minted licensed
driver yeah and she already got her
first moving violation really so in that
case
assuming you're you're you're you know
temperance for fairness yeah would you
revoke absolutely not
i might ask you to revoke i'm not
against i'm not against speeding
speeding has its time and place i i'm
not going to revoke a license over mere
speeding okay um it's really more about
the uh
kind of the the driver that doesn't is
not aware of the of the rules not the
one that that flouts the rules for
specific so what's i'm still trying to
get at what's behind this
this uh are you are you saying
irritation with people that don't follow
the rules it's not really that way what
is the temperament my irritation with
people who can't drive mm-hmm that's
when you you live in the wrong state
you should move to you know see you're
moving to germany or something you're
you're at that zone two heartbeat like
if if you see an idiot driver out there
that doesn't bother you
oh i get my i get i get ruffled okay
from time to time that's all i'm saying
yeah i know what that's like but i heard
that when you were at the drivers at
this dmv getting math is her license or
she got it herself she passed the test
yeah you ran into a friend of mine i had
a celebrity encounter at the dmv it was
a thousand oaks uh your buddy the the
the malibu artist carlos malibu artist
how was that was it a funny
name comes up with more regularity on
this podcast than most people
i know he's doing great work you know he
was just in florida or maybe he's still
there but he was um working in jupiter
out of jupiter florida he was reporting
on a shark fishing tournament
um where
there's this it's it's a
sanction tournament noah has given
permits to these boats or 57 boats in
the competition apparently
um only 12 came to weigh in 11 bull
sharks were taken
and it's a tournament that claims to
support conservation science and they
claim that hundreds of sharks were
tagged
on a catch-and-release basis but
undercover footage has since emerged
with tournament organizers saying
suggesting to the fishermen to kill as
many sharks as possible and don't
dispose the bodies don't just take the
jaws and toss them over
um because divers will go looking for
them and they're afraid of the
environmentalists to you know
sensationalize things
but the fact of the matter is um no
evidence of tag data registration has
emerged from this competition there's no
videos of tag and release that have been
put forward by the organizers
fishermen often do participate in
science
but there's no evidence that that
happened here
and so you know personally i have no
oven dead against fishermen i respect
anybody who dedicates their life to
being on the water
i don't respect
the you know sport hunting of beasts
like you know sharks at all you know
just out of curiosity how would you
steel man the support conservation
science argument behind this
like what is that argument their
argument was that they were tagging
sharks and then they were releasing them
so then the tags you know shark
scientists can then theoretically
track migration patterns and you can
learn about shark behavior
but in fact there was no in fact we
don't have any evidence there was
tagging i can't say there wasn't i just
don't that we haven't seen any evidence
emerge yet right and there and these
same organizers have planned to hold a
statewide tournament soon and that's
what's really
kind of like you see certain countries
like french polynesia has banned shark
fishing entirely uh sharks are a huge
part of the of the culture um it's
completely banned there hawaii shark
fishing is banned you can't do it um
there's no reason to have sport shark
fishing it's sharks are needed to
control certain populations that might
eat seagrass or kelp beds which are
important for
reabsorption of carbon they are the apex
predator therefore they manage the whole
ecosystem so when you remove sharks from
the water you you are damaging the
ecosystem i've written about this we've
talked about it before so this is kind
of an example of it it's a great it's a
great like 11 minute video um
in in uh malibu artist style so i
definitely urge you guys to check it out
yeah if you're watching on youtube
you're seeing clips from it and we'll
link the video up in the show notes of
course but it is amazing to me that
this is not outlawed
yeah and what is the
sort of legislative resistance to making
that happen well it's florida
it's a state by state thing um
in terms of hunting and fishing laws i
believe it is and now that the epa you
know that there's that supreme court
decision that was handed down that makes
it harder for um the epa to i guess
manage greenhouse gases i don't know
where that comes along in terms of this
you know bull sharks are not endangered
so that's probably part of it you know
you can
um you can hunt them i just think that
we need to think differently about
hunting and fishing laws um i'm not like
i said i'm not against fishing fishermen
doing their business and making a living
as long as it's an environmentally
sustainable way um i respect them uh
this is not that
aren't we on the cusp of shark week i
think it's happening
free diver that was swimming with the
tiger sharks he's in shark week this
week
yeah with friend of the pod paul the
gelder your friendly shark yeah but i
don't know if he's in that one he's with
i forget um who he's with it's someone
else we haven't talked about but she's
uh she's a reporter right um yeah it's
interesting that uh despite
mass enthusiasm for shark week that
uh the laws aren't changing more rapidly
i mean i would have to assume that shark
week helps
enhance
you know sort of public
awareness around
these issues in a positive way or does
it make people just scared of sharks i
mean paul's whole thing is helping
people to understand much like the
malibu artist
that you know these are these are
you know these are important animals
that we need to be protecting
yeah i mean hunting and fishing i've
been i've been diving around
professional divers for a long time and
i think that the awareness around
shark's contributions to the ecosystem
and its importance and and the fact that
they're not choosing to eat humans and
it's not they're not this predator to be
feared as much
is growing definitely so that's
happening it's just um you know the leap
from that to legislation is a different
thing uh you know i can't answer that i
will say that i think social media has
made activism actually more impotent to
be honest with you because like you
think that you're doing something by
tweeting or posting something on
instagram and you're not doing [ __ ]
because that doesn't do anything right
so um you know how you can do something
is is talking to people who make those
decisions so that if anything we can
learn from another thing we're going to
talk about soon i don't want to
you know but obviously the abortion um
issue
and roe v wade getting overturned is
that those were activists that were
definitely boots on the ground for years
and years and years and never stopped
and so like that's how that's how change
happens not by posting about it yeah it
is a weird thing because you have that
pres pressure valve release if you talk
about it on social media
but it's rather ineffectual i mean it's
it affects cool i suppose good if you
have a large platform and a large
audience it's important to say something
and you know share your perspective and
perhaps that can move the needle in
terms of public opinion but ultimately
change happens through relentless
pressure boots on the ground type
activism old school style
but you know let's get to that later
most important how the hell are you
i uh i feel good okay right now good
it's been an interesting couple weeks
um i'll start with uh my visit to
boulder which i guess was two and a half
weeks ago at this point
i traveled to boulder uh to do some work
with solomon who's my partner long-time
partner friend of friend of the podcast
podcast supporter
um they
were doing an event in boulder to
celebrate solomon's 75 75 years as a
company their 75th birthday which is
super cool
and also um to celebrate
their their best male ultra runner on
their team francois den who
is a wonderful human being and
incredible ultra running champion who
lives in france uh but had traveled to
the united states uh to get ready for
the hard rock 100 which just transpired
last weekend and so i was to do a q a
with francois and there was like an
event at this running store and there
was a fun run and all that kind of stuff
so i went it was great the q a was
amazing i was able to do also in
addition to that a podcast with francois
which went really well which we'll be
releasing at some point
um and also classic on the road yeah and
a real old school one with gordo byrne
who is a former ultraman world champion
who i'd never met in person
uh he's a coach and just a wise human
being and somebody i wanted to meet for
a very long time who's inspired me and
kind of mentored me from afar and we had
an amazing podcast so why is that old
school a real old school one just
because
he was an a very early and profound
influence on me when i was training for
ultraman as somebody who had had his own
life transformation from being kind of a
heavyset
investment banker hedge fund type guy
living in hong kong to transforming his
life
and and performing at the highest level
as an elite in ironman and ultraman so
he won ultraman he also got second at
iron man canada like he was training
with scott molina and living it like
full time like and he would share in the
early days of the internet on his
blogger wordpress whatever like stuff
that he learned and he had a little
podcast at the time
called endurance corner where he would
share training techniques etc and i just
learned a lot from him and he was very
helpful to me and it was cool to be able
to finally meet him so that'll be coming
out at some point as well but the point
being that
i had a great experience in boulder and
then on the flight home
i started to feel not so great what
happened it was very what was the first
symptom just you know a little
congestion a little heat in the forehead
you know a little scratchy like little
guy everyone was looking at with like
hate in their eyes i was
trying i had a little tickle
a tickle in the back of the throat
and it reminded me uh very vividly of my
experience flying home from miami less
than three months prior where i had
hosted a conference and interacted with
a lot of people
and and felt my first covet symptoms on
that flight and here i was again having
an analogous very similar experience
sure enough
covered round two
i think 11 weeks after i had had it the
first time bummer so that was not fun i
was down for the count for
six or seven days which is why we didn't
have a roll on the other week right i'm
feeling good now but it was interesting
it was different from
uh the first
go-around i'd be interested to hear from
other people who have had it multiple
times
first time i got it i had two
consecutive nights of pretty high fever
and chills this time i only had one so i
thought oh well maybe i'm going to get
over this more quickly
but then i had a couple days of
real depression and darkness and this is
something julie experienced when she had
it like it got really dark for her in a
not great way mentally health-wise and i
got a taste of that like not
suicidal per se i don't think it was
that severe but but definitely
this sensation of like nothing matters
and like what's the point
you know
i live there
that's where i live
yeah well i maybe i you know i was able
to crawl up into your skull for a couple
days yeah
pessimism was looming the dark cloud i
take nothing matters as a a point of
optimism yeah nothing matters but no but
seriously i did see you like had a
cryptic tweet in there where you're like
talking about i forget what it was it
was like i needed that today or
something like that i wonder if it was
aligned with
that moment so i know
i i think at some point i was like here
i go round two or something like that
but i don't think i shared anything
truly cryptic about that okay maybe i'm
wrong i don't know um but yeah so that
was different and new the second time
and then
just you know weakness and it lingered
for a while and then when i thought i
was
basically on the cusp of crawling out of
it and starting to feel better suddenly
i had a fever again on like day eight or
so did you have to retest
um yeah i was testing like every couple
days so yeah i was still positive
at that point so this one lasted a
little bit longer right i feel fine now
um but yeah
that's why i sent you that
twice that story that from yeah the thai
i don't even know i'm like reluctant to
even share this story but this this this
post on this site called the thai e t y
e e get ready for the forever plague is
the most
uh depressing
coveted story i've ever read i don't
know what's depressing about that
graphic fear fear-mongering you know
image to correspond to it but
essentially the thesis of this article
and i i would basically tell people not
to read this but it's basically what it
says is that it's not going away right
these variants are going to continue
uh the vaccinations and the boosters
can't keep pace with uh yes with the
complexity of the you know always you
know new and and different variants and
this is just something we're gonna have
to live with and not for nothing
once you've had it like we're seeing
uh the efficacy of like your own
immune system response dwindling and
we're seeing more and more people with
longer health
negative health
predicaments as a result of repeated
exposure right and i think what it's an
appeal to is basically uh
you know be smart continue to mask up in
certain environments it's not saying
it's not an advocation it's not
advocating um shutdowns at all
saying like if you're indoors in a tight
space you probably should still mask up
outdoors you're probably fine but
you know this idea that six feet is
enough is not really there either and um
and so and there is long-term health
that we're not hearing about like
long-term impacts on immune system and
immune response and and even vital
organs so they're they're finding this
stuff it's real science um we're not
hearing about it as much i think people
are also just don't want to bother with
it anymore because you know it's not
really something that's the case we're
seeing a huge spike in los angeles right
now nobody's messed up people are just
not willing to do it anymore well i
think we you know we've been abandoned
in some ways and getting information
from the leaders i think it's not we've
been abandoned we don't really want it
um
you know i think i i think
we
also just aren't mature enough to handle
the truth well we've also like we've
also been misled so many times without
pointing fingers like the the the public
policy response has been so bungled in
so many ways that there is a level of
distrust and people at this point want
to just get on with their lives you know
and right it is what it is i mean i
don't want to believe i don't want to
turn this into a you know covet no no
um
but i will say that it seems that covid
might be the price of international
travel these days i've heard it from
multiple people who've come back from
awesome getaways that got covered
just a lot of people are getting it
right now you've had
our swim teacher
for for zuma and a couple of his friend
like three of his friends
went to barcelona
for a couple of weeks
by the way swim teachers
they get paid so well now are you aware
of this i taught swimming in college did
you teach swimming growing up at all i
was a lifeguard and a coach but i never
taught swim lessons maybe i did briefly
i taught swimming you can you can you
can definitely charge a premium
especially in los angeles i think i made
25 an hour the most like in a private
lesson
these these swim teachers today i'm not
i'm not going to pinpoint her because
it's everyone i got quotes from multiple
it's like 30 bucks ahead for like a 30
minute lesson with toddlers so they'll
get it's not not for a private for a
group for a semi-private it's like 100
it's like lawyer money like 120 bucks
for 30 minutes it's amazing and of
course she goes to barcelona but then
she got coven and we didn't get her
we missed a we missed another week but
um
i hope she gets well yeah well one final
thing on this before we move off of it
the other weird thing that happened when
i had covet was
um you know as i've shared many times
i've had this lower back pain
but during covit that seemed to
exacerbate and in addition to that i had
insane insane
nerve pain down
um
the quad my right quadriceps that's
crazy so much so that i i couldn't move
my leg let alone put any weight on it so
i was like hobbling around like i needed
like crutches
and i believe it was a
pinched nerve at l2 l3 the pinched
lateral femoral cutaneous nerve
um
but it was unbelievably painful and that
happens from covet very
very acute experience that i've never
i've never had that before so i thought
well maybe all the lying down in bed
right you know created this
but i did come across some information
because of course you google it and then
you go down these crazy rabbit holes
right i don't know if this is the case
but
there does seem to be some evidence that
uh
that as a complication of covid19
there's this thing called acute
transverse myelitis which is
inflammation on both sides of one
section of spinal cord that damages the
insulating material covering nerve cell
fibers so essentially
so essentially
like inflammation of the
of the kind of the what what
covers the nerves
and uh and that inflammation caused an
impingem an impingement at l2 or l3 does
that regenerate and so i don't you know
i don't know i mean i there's you know
here's a research study that i can read
that i can link up um all i know is that
you know i was praying that it would
just go away and it did eventually oh
and i don't know whether it went away
yeah
i don't know if it went away naturally
as a result of me getting over covid but
i was also doing
electric stimulation therapy you know
these little devices
attach these electrodes to kind of
loosen up the muscles and that seemed to
that seemed to help but uh you know i'd
be curious if anyone else out there had
has experienced anything similar to that
interesting because i haven't heard of
anybody but uh it was very strange and
extremely painful but dude like i said
i feel good i'm back
generally it's getting better good yeah
it's getting slowly slowly getting
better building back a little bit um
trying to get reconnected with fitness
and doing all these little exercises to
improve glute strength and
pelvic mobility and all that kind of
stuff how is how are your glutes and
your pelvic mobility they are so awesome
right now
i was doing good and then covet hit and
i wasn't doing anything during that and
i got to be
really
you know one thing everybody has told me
is just be really conservative and
cautious about getting back into fitness
too quickly so you don't have some kind
of relapse so
that's it julie turned 60 this week
happy birthday julie yes on thursday as
a matter of fact the day this podcast
comes out so that's exciting
throw a big party for julie are you
throwing a big party um throwing a
little party at the house for her
friends nice she's fun and uh and yeah
man
she's gonna perform with the boys really
music fantastic it'll be good
um
so let's move off of this what else do
we want to talk about well first of all
let's take a minute to just recap the
fact that cory booker was on roll on you
mean cory booker my favorite uh my
favorite
wellness influencer he is he has become
he is your new self-help guru i get his
he posts every day videos every day of
empowering advice
it really is
you know so it was pretty cool i i think
what was funny about that is we were so
stoked that
we actually got his office to agree to a
15 minute amazing
and i was like being very cautious of
not trying to run over our time
allotment and be respectful of him and
if you listen to it i keep kind of
interjecting trying to end it and he was
like no i want to keep going and he kept
talking and i think we went for like 45
minutes which was unbelievable he was
fabulous you know inspiring and really
um
the voice we needed at that moment um it
was really cool of him to take the time
and to talk to us and the fact that he's
a listener and that he's on a run streak
inspired by
uh hella is this it's the same it's the
same thing that uh that
jason's on right basically yeah the run
streak right right right hella's reach
hella is
no boundary right he's just continuing
and hell is what seven years in he just
did like a birthday thing of it like
like yeah so he's
he's amazing uh and he's so inspiring
he's inspiring senators and it just
shows you what you can do what you can
do you know what social media is good
for which is this like this kind of some
ideas do get into the culture and he has
influence to change people's lives yeah
it's pretty cool yeah
um but anyway yeah senator booker that
was a great experience and yeah so yeah
it's we're we're i think we're on a bit
of a jag here because now we got malcolm
gladwell on the podcast this week that's
definitely like a huge get from day one
he was somebody i wanted to have on
um
took a long time to make it happen but
we made it happen he couldn't have been
cooler or more delightful i'm really
proud of that conversation we had a lot
of fun i think you had a chance to
listen to a little bit yeah yeah yeah on
the way i loved it it was it was it's
like it's like the perfect geek out
where you guys can just like you drop
into a topic and then you just
immediately go deep and then you go to
another because you have great overlap i
mean
right but it all comes back to running
yeah well running and then also but also
media yeah you also have media yeah
podcasting too so you know all of that
and
um his uh his new show legacy of speed
which is kind of it's built around um i
caught an episode of that which is you
know with coach bud winter and that
whole thing and it's like a perfect
uh gladwell deep dive into something
that we thought we understood or we've
all heard about and he shows it in such
new light right
really cool and i think i've said it in
the podcast it might be the most
gladwellian of all gladwell projects
ever because it has aspects of all the
things that he loves and is interested
in starting with track and field but
also when a certain group of people end
up at the same place at the same time
and some kind of magic ensues like
that's a big kind of recurring gladwell
trope
um and the intersection of like sport
culture politics
and and also of course
the sort of misunderstood aspect of all
of it because there was a lot that was
misunderstood about those protests what
they meant how they were interpreted at
the time and what happened to those
athletes as a result of taking that you
know really courageous stand yeah i mean
i think what happened to them is isn't
misunderstood i mean they they were uh
you know they they were basically
treated as pariah
and it wasn't respected it was like they
were widely thought that they
um
that they tarnished the olympics uh and
and
so i mean that that i think was very
clear and then i i forget which one of
them ends up in
um the desert as a professor or
something or as a coach one is it john
carlos i think it's john carter i could
be wrong but i think it yeah i think it
is john carl um
but you know you
reading about them later you obviously
you know by the time i came i became
aware of what happened it it it um
you know always respected those guys i
mean imagine the courage that took
uh in 1968 to do that and how selfless
that act was
now we see
kind of people speaking out on issues
and they make it kind of almost
performative but that was like really
they took a huge risk and suffered for
it
um
and it's remarkable you know and a lot
has changed and a lot hasn't when you
look at colin kaepernick right and
realize what he has suffered as a result
of the courageous stand that he took
yeah and also you know
contextualizing the impact of like bud
winter and professor harry edwards like
without those two guys at that place at
that time you don't get colin kaepernick
and you don't get usain bolt right usain
bolt coming from the bud winter uh
um strategy of relaxing relaxed
sprinting relaxed uh effort
um
yeah so it's all it's an amazing deep
dive uh really thank you for turning me
on to that i love that that you brought
up the lebron like malcolm challenging
lebron to a mile and yeah podcast with
him that was amazing i know i'd like to
see that happen i don't think lebron
ever got back to him
it's the risk is too high on his have
you seen that video though of lebron no
i want to see that
are you putting that in oh yeah
notes
well why don't let's uh let's take a
break quick break and we'll be back with
that and uh also some other kind of
related stuff to legacy of speed
profits walk among us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years i've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share those
that we don't know who can teach us
something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing
and so i've dedicated my career to
tracking down the most compelling
profits on the planet going deep with
each of them on my podcast
to elucidate the best of what they have
to offer and to sharing the insights
gleaned for the benefit of all
but the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories which is
why i'm proud to announce the release of
my new book
voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper voicing
change is a physical manifestation of
the magic
inspiration
and timeless wisdom that transpires each
week on the ritual podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table
and volume 2 follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite
conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts essays
and stunning photography making for an
exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying standalone work
picking up this book allows you to
revisit the wisdom of your favorite
everyday prophets
and physically interact with the
life-changing ideas contained within
change volume 2 available now while
supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
all right we're back before we i did
find the lebron video i'm going to show
that to you guys for a second those of
you who are watching on youtube but i
forgot to tell
this really embarrassing uh malcolm
story hey do i have your attention yeah
i'm just watching lebron i know come on
all eyes over here buddy i thought i was
supposed to be watching this no we're
getting to that in a minute oh okay um
so this is probably
i can't believe i'm gonna tell this
story um six years ago seven years ago i
can't remember i was in new york city
and i was going to be speaking at this
um event that was upstate
it was for engine 2 rip esselstyn's
uh company they were they do this annual
thing at the esselstyn farm called plant
stock and all these plant-based people
come and speak and it's
it's really fun actually i've done a
couple times so anyway i was taking the
train
north out of manhattan up into the
hudson valley and i got off at this
small town and somebody from the event
met me at the train station picked me up
and we're driving down like the main
street of whatever this little town was
on our way to truck you know sort of
travel out to this farm yep
and
and i'm just looking out the window and
we pass a cafe
and sitting out in front of the cafe
like eating a muffin is malcolm gladwell
oh you've told me this story yeah yeah
yeah this is a great story yeah it was
so
like the juxtaposition of like if i'd
seen him like walking down the street in
manhattan or jaw running in the park or
something like that like i would expect
like that would be
sort of to be expected right he's in his
natural environment i didn't realize
that he had a place upstate right i now
know that he you know that's where he
lives right so he lives i think yeah
probably all the time now
but six years ago i just thought he was
somebody who lived in manhattan and so
when i'm in this small town in the
middle of nowhere and i see malcolm
gladwell sitting by himself and running
you know in his running gear like eating
his breakfast
something came over me like and we live
in la you see celebrities all the time
right like i don't get like
i don't get like off kilter verklempt
use them use your
your inherited heritage's heritages
vernacular i get it um
but i lost all motor function and i like
rolled down the window and i just
blurted out like i love a revisionist
history like i completely lost control
of myself
and he kind of like looked over like uh
like side-eyed me and was kind of like
uh
that was like this story no i was too
embarrassed too and then i like kind of
rolled up the window and like then i
just slunk down into my seat like
like sort of embarra like oh my god i
can't believe i did that like i
literally it wasn't a conscious decision
it's just like something came over me
because like i have so much
respect for that guy and i'm such a fan
of everything that that that he does
um
truly you know that i just i was like
completely star struck see this is six
to seven years ago before
being a podcast super fan was cool
now like everyone is listening to
podcasts and so it's like it's like that
was just starting like it was just
starting to like you guys were and it
dated before that too through his books
and well of course but you know what i
mean it's like it's like podcast super
fandom which is now a normal thing
yeah it's weird that listeners that's
what i want you to take from this story
not only does he podcast he is a huge
podcast fan
are you not you're oh yeah
i am i love it so if you see me sitting
outside eating a muffin somewhere roll
your window down and blurt something out
i know that you listened to this episode
of the [ __ ] scream scream illegibly
um anyway i did find the video of lebron
uh blake's gonna pull it up right there
so basically he's doing laps around the
perimeter of a basketball court and he's
got a guy
posting up um
around the the free throw line on each
side
beating him basketballs and he's just
doing layups and dunking and stuff like
that and he's running
pretty fast and i think this video which
has something like this one has
4.6 million views it looks like
um is what led malcolm to think this guy
is an unbelievable endurance athlete and
if we were to do a mile challenge i
think he would beat me he is such a
beast man i mean like his his physical
conditioning is
second to none yeah i mean it's
interesting to hear him talk about
also the elite athletes and longevity
versus pink performance it's almost as
if like
because lebron is in his 20th year i
know 20th year
and he did you see him he was at the
you know they have the the
this kind of uh pickup type of game i
think it's called drew i forget i forget
what it's called but it they used to
they used to do it in um
in new york in a park
um and they they did it in a gym oh that
park down by fourth street yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i know what you mean
and so now they're doing a rucker park
or something they'd have it there
sometimes this was at a in a gym i don't
know where it was
i saw him in new york city in a gym like
working was that new york city yeah and
he
uh but no this is a basketball scenario
so he went with um demar derozan another
nba player and they went and played
against some of these guys that are
really good but not obviously at the nba
level and you know it's it's famous for
people coming in and trying and just
putting on shows and he hadn't been
there since 2011 and he just
you know took over the gym and owned it
was kevin love part of that too
he wasn't on the um
on the floor this time yeah he wasn't on
the floor this time it was him and demar
derozan were the two nba guys
um yeah
well on the subject of legacy of speed
and all things gladwellian i think it
dovetails pretty nicely into this next
story that we want to talk about which
is super interesting so yeah and even
even the lebron mentioned dovetails into
it because we're talking about
um
the greatest athlete in the first half
of the 20th century so if you you know
of his era um jim thorpe
who is this the winner of uh the 1912
olympic gold medal for the decathlon and
the pentathlon
uh also a professional baseball player a
college football
a renowned and like beloved college
football player before the olympics
pro football player after the olympics
he was just restored as the sole winner
of his 1912 olympic medals and when he
won him he destroyed the field it wasn't
even close
um and he was the star of the ticker
tape parade down broadway after that um
jim thorpe is of uh
uh indigenous heritage he's a native
american of the sock and fox so i don't
know how to pronounce it sauk and fox
nation in oklahoma
um and he grew up in those tribal
schools where the uh kids had to cut
their hair and they couldn't speak their
their native tongue and a similar kind
of order i don't exactly know where you
know how his school compares the ones in
canada but you know people were a lot of
children were mistreated and even died
under the care of these tribal schools
there was a big controversy of these
masquerades that were that that were
found in canada certainly some abuse
happened in america too so he's a
product of those schools
um but becomes this amazing athlete
you know takes over the olympics along
with duke uh konomoko who is the other
star happened to be native hawaiian and
they became friends on the steamship
over to the 1912 olympics
um which is like a scene out of chariots
of fire yeah just unbelievable these two
native guys representing america having
been
um you know
victims of america um yet recommend but
yet also representing and and showing
with pride and dominating and anyway uh
a year not even maybe less than a year
after winning those olympic medals and
being celebrated
he had his medal stripped
uh because he had earned 25 a game
playing minor league baseball when he
needed money uh years before the
olympics which is where it intersects
with legacy of speed yeah and the kind
of legacy of avery brundage the ioc
president who had this fanatical
concept of what it meant to be an
amateur athlete
and and his staunch position that
politics and sport should never
intersect
but that allegiance to this idealized
notion of amateurism
you know played into decisions that
brundage made over the many decades
that he lorded over the ioc
obviously this is many years
prior to that but that concept comes
into play like i've never heard this
story but the fact that like okay
he had to he had you know he had to pay
some bills he had to like make a little
money so he picked up 25 bucks to play
a different sport like semi-pro baseball
or whatever which was like it's not
baseball as we think of it it wasn't a
major league no it wasn't yeah and and
they used that to strip him of his gold
medals like i didn't even know that that
had happened and not only strip him but
that made him in ill
in ineligible to again compete in 1916
and 1920 um and you know because at that
time the decathlon champion was the best
athlete in the world that was the
revered and right is it remain that way
all the way through
um you know probably through 76 with
bruce jenner was kind of the peak of
that but in 1912 um he got in 1913 he
gets stripped and so he what does he do
he goes and plays pro baseball right and
he plays what's interesting is he went
to this small school called carlisle
right right and then in 1911 they beat
harvard right and harvard was the best
team because of him because because he
was so dominant and he was like a
running back and a kicker and so he
played pro baseball for whatever 670
seasons and then in 1920 he decides to
play pro pro football and he plays till
he's 41 years old and he's like one of
the best football players maybe the best
so
um i mean this is one of the great
athletes ever and he's now been restored
as the sole winner i think it's uh some
years after
uh he was he was again restored as like
co-winners like they they elevated right
the guys they elevated in the 80s they
they made him co-winner like so he had
to share his gold with the people that
he actually beat and he was i mean i
don't know i think he was he he was dead
then already right and and in you know
when the other guys to their credit when
they were told they won they were like
no they weren't really stoked on the
idea of being told they won because it's
weird because they know they were there
it wasn't their decision they knew they
got their asses handed to them like now
they're supposed to like wear this gold
medal right and so now he's restored as
you know what is it a hundred ten years
later and he's taking 110 years to
set matters to rights on this which is
crazy and and my sense from that article
was that the the reinstatement of his
titles happened kind of quietly right it
was it was a native american publication
that's right that somehow picked up on
the story and and ultimately how it
ended up in the new york times but it
wasn't like there was a press release or
any kind of big announcement around no
and jim and and you know jim thorpe aka
bright path strong which is i mean what
a what a name that's ballsy is golden
again why has there never been a biopic
about this guy can you imagine today a
guy who wins let's say he didn't get his
amateur status revoked so he wins golden
decathlon and pentathlon pentathlon
doesn't exist anymore there is
pentathlon it's different in the winter
olympics right um he returns in 1916 and
and and wins again then he goes it like
that could have happened right well
that's what duke that's what happened
with dude
he kept going back he didn't take the
biopic is the relationship between those
two guys yeah telling those two stories
i think but
then for thorpe to go on
play pro baseball for six years and then
play pro football for until he was 41
but he started in 1920. so how many
years what was that 15 years or
something like that i mean he's out of
college in 1911 like nine years after
college no no other athlete in modern
history in the second half no of the
century has been able to do the only
thing you can think of is uh david
robinson who is an elite college
basketball player and then he had to
take a year off before going to college
to play to be able to play pro he had to
stay in the navy for like a year was
supposed to be five years but they let
him out at i think it was a year they
gave him a special dispensation um was
he on the olympic basketball team also i
think i believe he was yeah but i think
he was on the olympic basketball team as
a pro later when it was okay it's for
pros to play
um i think he was different this is
different yeah
um but yeah super interesting to read
that after listening to legacy of speed
yeah he was i think david robinson might
have been on the 88 olympic team and the
90 to he was on the dream team for sure
i would think i mean he was that year or
maybe i think so yeah yeah i don't know
too old to remember
um anyway uh that's an amazing story
somebody should definitely make that
movie though yeah
i mean i
probably could find it i wonder if
there's ever been one but there should
be one you know there must be some kind
of documentaries anymore now it's got to
be a limited edition netflix limited
series limited series or a push can uh
limited series podcast or a
in a serious ritual
should we move into that we'll see
um the next story is is also quite
amazing and this
you know created kind of a tidal wave of
news across the world
um it's a story about mo farah the the
legendary track and field athlete he he
disclosed in a documentary that i
believe is coming out this week
um by the bbc that
he had
been trafficked to the united kingdom
from somalia three decades earlier under
a false name and had been essentially a
house servant yeah for many years until
he finally
told his gym teacher at school what
actually was happening yes and
apparently the authorities were apprised
of this he was able to get out of that
and
and the like but he's kind of quietly
held this secret for a very long time
crazy can you imagine can you imagine
being so
gifted and celebrated as an athlete but
also
um
you know carrying that secret for so
long
you know all the way through being
knighted
it's unbelievable i mean this guy yeah
in 2000 he was granted uk citizenship
2012 he won two golds in the olympics
the 5k and the 10k 2016. he repeated
with golds in both of those events
despite
accidentally getting tripped in the 10k
and still winning 2017 he gets ignited
and then he kind of hangs up the the
spikes in track and field gets into the
marathon and runs 205. unbelievable
2018. unbelievable i mean
i think he's going to run the the london
marathon this year yeah um so on the and
he does well in london avery brundage
slavery avery what would what would
avery brundage
you know have made of uh mo farah's
amateur status
because why and his uh his relationship
with amateurism
because he'd been uh or because he
wasn't really a citizen of england or
something like that yeah i mean he would
yeah basically like he's not really a
city it would have it would have given
you know
his racism an excuse to support him he
would have found he would have found a
way
um
but uh
anyway the new york times wrote a
there's a couple there's two stories in
the new york times about this talia
minsberg my editor wrote the first one
which kind of came on the heels of the
you know right before the bbc
documentary so she was the one to kind
of break this for them and then
um this this other one uh i think it's
jarrett longman jerry longman uh i don't
know how to pronounce the first name
that's the second one here how mo farah
outran yeah and that's someone who has
covered him
many
times um
and kind of knows his story back and and
and forth
um and so uh you know that's a good one
too uh it's crazy crazy
to think of
that but it's not uncommon you know east
africa has had that sudan um there's
been uh people who've been smuggled out
of sudan they think they're
or they're told they're coming they're
coming over and they're gonna earn money
as a as a domestic worker in um say
saudi arabia or in the arabian peninsula
and then are uh not given any money and
are are basically like the fishermen
that you've seen that you've heard about
on you know the burmese fishermen on
thai fishing boats you know there is
slavery to this day happening i mean
sure there is and this is an example of
it it's good that but it's i can't
recall another instance in which
a super high profile person never has
disclosed no this happened no this is
yeah this is this is a whole nother
level and he even had an autobiography
that this wasn't in right yeah yeah
that's the thing yeah so imagine the
courage of of coming out and disclosing
this i guess there were some rumblings
about how that would affect his uk
citizenship and and you know downstream
of that like would he be able to retain
his olympic titles right but they've
kind of put that to rest that's not
gonna happen right he was a victim and
he was underage sure as as it should be
yeah um i love this quote um in this
article pharah's racing style was not
dissimilar to the way he faced the
vicissitudes of his life
starting from behind
persevering lap after lap patient and
resilient then finishing with an
illuminating sprint to the tape
amazing beautiful guy i'd love to i'm
going to rewatch the 1912 uh
10 000 i mean 1912 excuse me 2012 uh 10
000 meter is that stuff on youtube oh
yeah yeah any race you want any concert
you want it's all on youtube right right
did you watch the the old bud greenspan
olympic movies like 16 days to glory
oh they're fantastic
really you made one about the 1984
olympics called uh 16 days of glory i
think you would like but he was sort of
the official documentarian of the
olympic movement in the modern era and
there's tons of his stuff on on youtube
see but you know we're talking about jim
thorpe and you know
mo farah and and uh and
uh juan carlos and and um
tommy smith it's like
the idea of stripping people banning
people boycotting um the more i think
about it the more ridiculous it is and
it's like wimbledon just happened the
russian athletes couldn't play there i
mean these are not russian athletes that
are involved in any way in the ukraine
invasion they just can't play because
they they're in russia or 1984 i think
it was a mistake to uh
1980 in 1980 it was a mistake for us to
to boycott the soviet yeah and then 1984
is a mistake for them to boycott in in
response the united states uh la
olympics so it's like
all of that i think it's very clear
those are mistakes
and it's always better to get all the
best athletes out there together it's
the only way to if sports is going to
help in any way deal with world issues
all the athletes have to be present
that's my opinion on it yeah i mean this
came up in the in the conversation with
malcolm this idea he does a whole
episode in legacy of speed
on this subject of exit voice or loyalty
right and and
to boycott is to exit
you can use your voice as these athlete
activists did or you can be loyal and
fall into line with the avery brundages
of the world and i think if history
tells us anything it's that voice is the
most powerful and over time history you
know always favors the bold when it
comes to that i mean has anybody
performed a high level
high visibility protest at something
like the olympics or the olympics itself
that decades later you think yeah that
was a misstep like usually
it ends up being a really powerful
symbol for some kind of necessary
positive cultural shift or change yeah i
mean in this case obviously
they suffered in the immediate term but
now yeah they pay the price short term
yeah but long term it is
you know it's a lever for
for progress i think i mean i think
muhammad ali is the best example of
someone who um
refused to go to join the army refused
all the entreaties to it'll be easy you
don't have to go to war blah blah he
just said no i'm not a part of your uh
machine
and became even more of a hero
yeah yeah shifting gears yep we need to
report on an update in the
uh
case that we referred that we discussed
uh at length was it the last time we did
yeah i know so true crime if you listen
to the last roll-on that we did i think
it was the last one i think it was um we
discussed the murder of this
professional gravel cyclist mo wilson
yep um and the the the leading suspect
in that case being caitlin armstrong the
girlfriend
of
another professional cyclist colin
strickland
um sort of this weird love trying
triangle thing i don't want to rehash
all the details of the relationship that
led to this but when we last left off
over six weeks ago
caitlin armstrong
had had sort of disappeared she was in
the wind she was in the wind she was on
the lamb
a photograph of her
at laguardia airport in classic kind of
security footage blurry you know yeah uh
take uh
you know was seen why is security
footage always blurry well that was the
meme with the webb telescope did you see
this gun around like we're going to talk
about the web the web the images from
web being like yeah it's like on the one
hand the web image of like we can see
billions of years into the past and then
on the other hand security footage from
10 feet away
and you can't make out the person's face
yes yes yeah in the era of like you know
incredible uh photography on cell phones
you'd think like we can upgrade our
security camera i know anyway
yeah it was a
you could see it in lots of the press
like it's a very blurry image it's
surprising that you could even tell it
was her right and
jones knew it was her yeah exactly so
fugitive on the lam the us marshals are
on the hunt yes and it literally took
six weeks
to run her down but she was captured
in
costa rica right nice town called santa
teresa which is kind of a surf spot
in this place called don john's lodge
yeah where she was using an alias ari
martin and kind of teaching yoga and
staying in hostels but not necessarily
hiding kind of like living her life and
and we're we're you know we're kind of
joking around about it i mean it's quite
tragic moe wilson was beloved um she by
all accounts i mean i had never met her
but she was a wonderful human being and
she was literally slain in cold blood by
this woman caitlyn armstrong who split
i think the the the leading kind of idea
is that i think she was seen at newark
airport like she flew to laguardia and
then there were four days where she was
unaccounted for but apparently her
sister lives in upstate new york and
then she shows up at newark airport and
that's where she catches the flight to
costa rica she had a valid passport just
not her own and i think the idea is that
she borrowed her or stole her sisters i
don't know if that's verified okay um
and you know goes down there and bops
around taking buses and
spending time in hostels and little surf
villages throughout costa rica crazy
until finally these marshals i'm still
not clear entirely how they tracked her
down
maybe it was uh
following this this passport i'm not
sure maybe she was like working as a
yoga instructor she dyed her hair she
changed her name
um they did find a receipt for
63 hundred dollars for plastic surgery
that had a different name on it the
implication being that she had undergone
plastic surgery i guess she was seen
with a band-aid on her nose why would
you keep that receipt like can you
return the plastic surgery i don't i
don't know for tax purposes why would
you keep that receipt yeah
so i mean this story is bananas yeah is
it not and and this
you know i just pulled up
an article from the boston globe i mean
there is a you know two photos of her
before and after and she does look she
doesn't look any different she's got
different colored hair maybe not depends
i mean i you would have to know her i
suppose but i mean that looks like two
different people to me doesn't it i mean
the one thing i'll say which i said at
the time which was right before
the shooting in nouvel day was that like
if she didn't have access to a gun
her
um
mental health breakdown would not have
led to the shattering of three plus
lives i think the gun
and the end i could be wrong about this
but i think the gun was owned by colin
strickland no i think they bought them
like they bought it they both had i
think they both had them if i remember
correctly but it's been a while since i
read it but um
yeah i mean
she shouldn't have been empowered to be
able to take the life of mo wilson the
other interesting thing is that uh
at the at the onset of the case
she was obviously a suspect and they
brought her in for questioning
based on
an outstanding warrant that was already
out there
because she had skipped out on paying a
paying for botox like 600 bucks or
something like that okay and so they
used that warrant to bring her in
but apparently there was an error on the
warrant like they had her date of birth
wrong or something like that so they had
to release her so that
basically she then knew like oh man i
need to get out of dodge quickly and she
immediately went and sold her jeep for
like twelve thousand dollars and that's
when she split
but did she like what did she think like
she did she
delude herself into thinking she was
just gonna build this whole new life
down in costa rica and no one would be
the wiser what a crazy story man
anyway my heart goes out to mo wilson's
family yes and her friends
i'm sorry i'm glad that that this person
is in custody now and she's being
charged with first-degree murder as well
as a you know battery of other charges
switching gears
segway
we need some sound effects i know
jason can you work on that
uh switching gears um in in
news from the headlines of of people
running across the united states another
recurring old-school theme of the
roll-on podcast right like yes
people tend to do this frequently people
you know tend to run across
all countries i would say this person is
an internet friend we haven't met in
person yet but i'm going to get him on
the podcast soon we're trying to
schedule it his name is mike wardian and
he recently ran from san francisco to
rehoboth beach on the east coast in
delaware
um
michael is a very accomplished elite
ultra
runner he's 48 now
and he's got this you know giant beard
and he does kind of evoke this forrest
gump you know he does yeah he does look
like a stunt double um
and
what i like about him
is that he
you know he has a normal life too like
he's this incredible runner but
he's also
uh
you know he also
works as a partner in an international
ship brokerage firm i don't know what
that means yeah it sounds like a real
job does that mean he's like
he's brokering and like he's broke cargo
ships or
cargo like i think like shipping like
shipping both like you know cargo boats
who knows like
we need to get to the this will be the
focus of the podcast what do you do i
need to know more about international
ship brokerage yeah
um he's got two kids seems like he's got
a wife two
dogs he seems like a super cool guy yeah
um and and here's the thing he ran
across the united states
and he did it in 61 days amazing
so just for context robbie ballinger
who's an absolute beast
did it in 75 days so this guy did it
literally two weeks faster
3234 miles 132 2 000 feet in elevation
change running more than 50 miles a day
basically along for i think for the
majority of this run along route 50
right and raising money for world vision
trying to provide clean drinking water
to the developed world so
that's pretty cool shout out to mike my
favorite anecdote was the stray dog that
came upon them in missouri yeah and they
named him yellow i guess it must have
been a yellow lab and ran alongside them
for 40 miles
that's a pretty cool story it's a cool
story 40 miles yeah and i like how this
story was picked up by people magazine
oh really yeah look at this got such a
happy vibe like i loved i loved reading
about him today it's like it's like the
perfect it's actually the perfect thing
to wash down
the world with so uh i would definitely
click on this you guys in the show notes
yeah i like how in the people magazine
article at the bottom it says related
video 12 year old golden retriever
returns to boston marathon after
miraculously surviving tumor we need
more good news like that
yeah we do
you're saying there needs to be more cat
videos is what you're saying we need
more cat videos i'm down with that more
here's uh the washington post did an
article on him too he lives in he lives
in arlington my old stomping grounds the
metropolitan washington dc area that's
right so anyway good on you buddy did
you grow up in where did you go you were
silver spring right bethesda bethesda
yeah been there
i think mike also ran the the perimeter
of the beltway which is like 90 miles
like he's done some other cool stuff
i've been there too name another place
name another place just name a place
we're not playing
one place we all know you're the lonely
planet guy one place what's the
loneliest place on the planet that
you've been oh
um
the loneliest place on the planet here's
mike with his wife and kids and dogs see
like what's not to love about this dude
i know
um the only loneliest place on planet
i've ever been rich
is in my own head
there you go
that's the best answer
all right
uh moving on so much news from the world
of ultra industrial yeah we got
so much more to get through so
let's take a quick break and we'll be
back we'll be back with news from the
hard rock 100 from bad water
uh
and then we got some heavier stuff to
cover some listener questions and more
cool let's sell some products
sorry to interrupt the flow we'll be
right back with more awesome but i want
to snag a moment to talk to you about
the importance of nutrition the thing is
most people i know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to
incorporate more whole plants more
fruits vegetables seeds beans and
legumes into their daily routine sadly
however without the kitchen tools and
support very few end up sticking with it
so
because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly and
because i want everybody to experience
some version of what i've experienced
we decided to tackle and solve this very
common problem the solution we've
devised i'm proud to say is the plant
power meal planner our affordable
all-in-one digital platform that sets
you up for nutrition excellence by
providing access to thousands of highly
customizable super delicious and easy to
prepare plant-based recipes everything
integrates with automatic grocery
delivery and you get access to our
amazing team of nutrition coaches seven
days a week and many other features to
learn more and to sign up visit
meals.richroll.com and right now for a
limited time we're offering 10 off an
annual membership when you use the promo
code rr health at checkout this is
life-changing stuff people for just a
dollar seventy a week literally the
price of a cup of coffee again that's
meals.richroll.com promo code rrhealth
for ten dollars off an annual membership
all right let's get back to the show
all right we're back we got news from
the hard rock 100.
late on me so the hard rock 100 is one
of the most prestigious and difficult
ultra races in the world
uh it is this loop that that kind of
traverses southern colorado san juan san
juan range oh it has 66 000
feet of elevation gain i've been there
and this is like a showdown race
ever like durango out of durango
telluride durango silverton yeah i think
it starts and ends in scene 10. one year
they go clockwise one year they go
counterclockwise
um
francois den who i referenced earlier
this year he won it last year uh
and um
broke killian journey's course record
and he was returning this year to defend
his title super cool guy
originally hailing from the beaujolais
region of france fintner like making his
own wine
he gave me a bottle of his wine i didn't
have a heart to tell him that i don't
drink right uh but if only your co-host
he's since moved more to the mountains
but right just a really sweet guy family
guy with kids who's this unbelievable
ultra athlete also super tall
ultra runner how cool is that yeah very
cool yeah dude
um who's just crushing it right now he's
also i think he's won utmb five times
like everyone knows killing jordanae but
not as many people particularly in north
america are familiar with francois but
he's just an unreal talent was how do
you pronounce his last name dan den okay
dehayne de hayne would be the butchering
of it but i think francois denn
that's good
that's very good
and uh so it's gonna be a showdown
between francois and killian and uh they
right out of the gate pretty much ran
together throughout the majority of the
race along with this um
other amazing athlete dakota jones they
ran as a threesome yep
kind of trading lead i think dakota was
out in front for quite some time but
ultimately uh killian prevailed francois
was second
killian broke francoise
record
and
was crowned the victor for the fifth
time at this race unbelievable
21 hours 36 minutes uh francoise record
was 21.45 set last year
and francois ran 21.51 so it's crazy
that in a race this long this much
elevation gain that literally you know
only a couple minutes separated
separated them and dakota ended up third
in 2306.
in addition uh courtney dewalter finally
conquered this race
was the first to cross the finish line
in the women's category and it's also
the first time that she's actually
finished the race last year she ran into
digestive problems that sidelined her
and of course as is courtney's want
broke the women's course record running
26 hours 44 minutes i think she was
sixth overall i could be wrong about
that um
but just kind of unbelievable
performances unbelievable around you
know all the way across the board in
second place was stephanie case who ran
33-52 so that gives you a sense
of just how much faster
courtney is than everyone else because
whereas the men's race was fairly tight
right um courtney won by a significant
margin and hannah green came in third at
34 hours 26 minutes but epic race uh
and very cool to see that i think ultra
running needs like a rivalry like this i
think these guys are friends and they
get along really well but um cool to see
you know two athletes really at the top
of their game like going
tet for you know
almost 24 hours i'm believing hours
which is cool yes and then
this same weekend the bad water 135 went
down is it always like that is hard rock
and bad water always on the same way i
don't know that's a good question yeah i
should know the answer that i don't i
don't think they're generally i was
surprised to see them on the same
weekend
so
this is 135 miles through death valley
and
and uh up the mount whitney portals
everyone knows it knows about it being
like you know that the race that's in
the hottest place on earth temperatures
can reach around 120 degrees there's
stories of
um shoe soles melting on the pavement et
cetera but there's also an unbelievable
amount of elevation gain and that last
13 miles when you're going up the
portals you've probably been up there
right i've been there it's steep like
you're literally going straight uphill
yes for the last half minute i can't
imagine i can't imagine running this
insane race or even walking it um harvey
lewis front of the pod uh won it last
year
um he came in what he got he got what he
got fourth this year i think right
um
i don't want to get that wrong
uh yeah he finishes 11th bad water in
fourth place he ran 27 hours 16 minutes
unbelievable um but really cool his
partner kelly o'dell completed her first
bad water in 46 hours and 57 minutes
there's a 48-hour cut off yes so she
made it you know within an hour of that
48 hour cut off which is really cool
um but the winner was
the course record holder uh yoshihiko
ishikawa who won for the second time he
negative split the course which is
unbelievable running 23 hours and eight
minutes
um he set the course record in 2019 with
21 hours 33 months
and the legend there is that when he
crossed the finish line he proposed to
his girlfriend so that's pretty good
um that's how you do it
where it gets interesting
here in bad water and then say and then
marry me my darling you better hope she
says yes
if you win bad water i guess yeah
they're gonna say yes
where this whole story gets interesting
is is in the women's race so ashley
paulson who's a professional triathlete
and a pretty well-known ifit instructor
um
set the new female course record
uh with with a bit of a question mark
there's a there's a sort of let's just
say there's a little controversy
swirling around i read about this yes so
she ran 24 hours and nine minutes she's
coached by ryan hall she got third
overall so one place ahead of harvey and
she beat the course record by a little
bit under four minutes but the
controversy
um is sort of multi-fold and it begins
with a six-month usata ban that she
received when she was a triathlete
testing positive for something called
osterine which is a selective androgen
receptor modulator in sarm
she's held firm on her innocence
um so that was you know look that was
seven years ago six years ago
but there's also been
past allegations of course cutting there
was a half marathon where there's a lot
of kind of controversy around her her
finishing time
uh in this particular bad water she had
an unbelievable finishing split that
sort of defies logic yeah i think i
think only one of the fastest in the
last you know several years only one of
them
one man if you look at that which is the
hardest part like we said 13 miles right
up the portals like ishikawa was slower
than her and and uh and and um
harvey lewis is everyone except for one
guy has has beaten that time over the
past i think the last 20
uh male fastest times or something like
that there was a there's a graph on that
and apparently there were some
observations on the course and now
there's an investigation underway
there's a website called marathon
investigation where there's a post all
about this uh which i'll link up into
the show now so this is you know look
more will be revealed here it's unclear
exactly what transpired all i'm saying
is that there are some questions being
asked about her performance and there
are people who are trying to
get to the bottom of it on her instagram
she posted something about like i'm
posting my garmin data like she's aware
that there's controversy and obviously
and and she's you know defending herself
so
yeah at this point i don't i don't know
i wasn't there all i know is that here
is this article and
take it for what it
you know what you wish here's the if
you're watching on youtube here's the
list of
splits for that last sec
faster than scott
you know yeah yeah exactly yeah so it's
just you know it's reasonable to be
asking questions right now and you know
in the event that something untoward
happened it's just disappointing like
this is you know
one thing that's so beautiful about the
ultra running world and community is
there is a certain kind of you know
purity to it and not to be in an at you
know a sort of a aubrey brundage you
know purist on amateurism right you're
very awkward right now it's uh you know
there is something kind of you know
there's no it's not like prize money or
anything like that like you know people
are doing this for the love and so
you're revoking her life her bad water
license if if i'm doing nothing of this
sort
camille herron another friend of the pod
has weighed in on this as well you can
see her comments in this in this blog
post not
marathoninvestigation.com as well
um yeah so kind of
you know podcast roundup with francois
killian courtney harvey lewis camille
herron all of these names coming up all
all past you know
past guests on the podcast popular
basket
podcast guests in the past right which
is cool right yeah i mean that's this is
the bread and butter baby
um
we were gonna talk about the tour de
france but i got to tell you i'm not
enough up to speed right
i'm not
i'm not either my attention was devoted
elsewhere so maybe next time
uh we can chime in with some thoughts
there the only thing i'll say is that my
new favorite rider is magnus
court the dane with the mustache just
crushing it early into the polka dot
jersey and just continued to be in
breakaways and winning stages with flair
on the ef team i love that guy but
just the other day he got coveted had to
drop out of the tour de france damn
that's kind of the end of my tour of
france commentary for now
kovid
kovet on the tour kovitz never it just
keeps going i know
um should we weigh into the sticky
waters of our main topic today which
we've we've promised not to spend more
than five or six minutes on six minutes
three minutes each actually four minutes
we decided you just randomly decided six
minutes was the limit for this i
randomly decided because when we were
talking about it you were like it's been
a while but we should say something we
have discussed this in the past when the
leak happened that this was going to go
down
um we had a longer discussion about it
and and of course talking about the
dobbs case and the overturning of rovers
and the clock is ticking so go adam okay
clarence thomas seems cool
right am i right um
so
on the one hand i want you know when i
heard about this all i want to do is
listen to lily allen sing [ __ ] you you
know your point of view is medieval [ __ ]
you very very much
we hate you and we hate your whole crew
that kind of song you know that song
it's a great song
um but hate will not win this fight
and what we're dealing with are people
boots on the ground people who really do
think they are saving babies lives they
do
um sure i don't agree with that
perspective i think it's a skewed
perspective everyone loves babies on
both sides of this fight it's it's it's
it there's something grotesque about
trying to to suggest that that one group
people likes babies more it's ridiculous
um but
um
that said that is their point of view so
like
we
you know we need to be able to meet that
with love as well and we have to
understand that so you know
they're unified in their purpose
they are outnumbered and yet still
manage to get this through
um
and we can't even decide this is we
can't even say out loud that this is a
women's rights issue because there was
someone who was testifying in front of
josh hawley and made josh hawley seem
reasonable
um saying that it's not a woman's issue
of course it's a woman's issue because
of
certain words that are supposed to be
said
we can't even say that so that's why
we're getting beat um
and it's it's upsetting um i was
listening to diggable planets lately
1993 album throwback uh throwback album
uh le femme fatale is a song on that
record um
and here's a lyric if roe v wade was
overturned would not the desire remain
intact leaving young girls to risk their
health doctors to botch and watch as
they kill themselves that's what we're
dealing with that was a 1993 album uh
clarence thomas's name checked in that
as an enemy of roe
um and and it's come to fruition that
shows you how long people who've wanted
to overturn roe v wade have been working
and they've been working even longer
than that i think you're going to get
into it um
the one thing of the links that you
shared with me
is that i didn't realize kind of
clarence thomas's motivation and going
back i think that's a really interesting
story about um how he was actually a a
black radical
um very influenced by malcolm x which is
you know not what you would suspect yeah
and he he ended up on the in the
conservative wing of things because of
his distress for white liberals
uh like ourselves but mostly white
liberals who are kind of giving uh
more like
weren't really out to change anything
but we're more out to make it less bad
at least that's what this article kind
of is written by i think
columbia law professors it's a very
interesting opinion piece i i highly
recommend it it was it was very
eye-opening it's important to know where
people are coming from
but in the end what this comes down to
the human rights issue and you know on
the one hand uh you can't tell people
not to carry a gun you can't tell people
to wear a mask but you can tell women
what to do if they get pregnant by rape
i mean it's it's grotesque
yeah another interesting
uh
kind of nuance to this article is
the extent to which
the left
has attacked thomas
in
you know a pretty bald-faced racist way
right yeah the party who's meant to be
for
um
the expansion of human rights like sort
of defaulting to some you know not not
so great behavior phrasing yes
but yeah listen you know i'm i'm
pro-choice i believe in a woman's right
to choose i think this decision is
wrong-headed for
a multitude of reasons
and it's dispiriting and and
disappointing and and frightening
um but i think it's important to
understand
the context in which this exists it is
in many ways the culmination of
you know a 50-year campaign
to undo roe versus wade and they have
succeeded in that by having a very
long-term strategy that dates all the
way back to the 1970s and i think what
is truly fascinating about all of this
is the history behind the anti-abortion
movement
um i
sort of always assumed that
the christian right or the
kind of
evangelical uh
population of this country has
historically and always been
anti-abortion
but that's actually not the case there's
a really amazing article in
on politico about
this history
it's called the religious rite and the
abortion myth and it really unearths
the beginning of
conservative activism in this uh in this
terrain and basically what happened was
that
in the 1970s these
evangelical churches
were attempting to double down on
segregation and in response the irs was
going after them with the one tool that
they have which is to revoke their
tax-exempt status to sort of strong-arm
churches to abandon their segregationist
policies
and in response evangelicals realized
that doubling down on on
segregation probably wasn't going to win
hearts and minds right
and and allow them to avoid
the you know irs's strategy of revoking
their tax-exempt status so what did they
do they end up changing the narrative
they flip the script
and they make it all about government
intrusion
and their the kind of tip of the spear
for that government intrusion
narrative
was adopting
anti-abortion as the cause to rally
their base and garner support and they
were very successful in doing that
because
prior to that where it gets fascinating
is that prior to the 1970s the church
and we're setting catholics aside
actually cared very little about
abortion and as the history kind of
bears out they supported it in many if
not most cases this was not a thing
right until this irs you know kind of
that's the whole point situation it's
like the reason people think they're
saving lives of babies is because
they've been convinced of that it's not
it's and and and that starts here that's
where this comes from
this idea that like that that's how they
whipped people up into into a frenzy to
and it's funny that they did this to
avoid government intrusion into their
affairs that's nice
yeah it's super interesting yeah yeah
yeah the irony there yeah is is pretty
palpable so here we are um
you know it's retrograde in so many ways
yeah you know i don't even know where to
begin uh we've already you know sort of
eclipsed our six minutes but there's
plenty more to say about this before we
move on i think
it's going to be
really interesting like how this gets
played out and how it will ultimately
end up getting enforced state by state
right i think
you know obviously if you're well healed
you're going to be able to get access to
an abortion yeah if you're in a red
state or a state where it's outlawed and
it's difficult
we're already seeing situations in which
women are being persecuted medical
practitioners are being persecuted and
the kind of next culture war is how are
we going to regulate and police the
abortion pill because a huge percentage
of abortions carried out in the us and
and internationally
is via this abortion pill which is a two
pill regimen the first is a hormone
blocker to kind of arrest the conception
and the second is what causes the
discharge or the hemorrhage
and that pill is by prescription and
right now there are
um kind of online telehealth sources for
that that are overseas that are in
states where it's legal
so what's going to happen when all of
this goes into effect and in many places
it already has
how are you know what is what is access
to those pills going to look like and
how are states going to enforce or
regulate that access
are they going to go after the women
like it's not possible right so we're
going to enter this weird prohibition
era type situation where
either people are going to be
you know kind of under the table
trafficking in this stuff or there
really will be a true black market but
networks are going to get set up
to provide people with access to this
and i think
a very likely scenario is that
a lot of women will end up and i'm not
recommending this but they'll be able to
get access to that second pill because
it's prescribed for ulcers
and if you go to your doctor and say you
have an ulcer you can get the second one
and there seems to be some efficacy
in using just the second pill without
the first if you do it within the first
10 weeks i think is the window yeah but
not recommended right so we're going to
enter that era of
you know kind of
backroom dubious practices that are
driven out of desperation re-enter that
round re-enter of course yeah
yeah i mean it's it's it's uh
it's people are not gonna stop having
sex no and there's they're you know
they're not gonna stop there's not you
know there's not gonna be a halt to
unwanted pregnancies no they happen and
and we don't it's not like this is being
met with
uh an increase in funding and
intentionality going into
federal and state programs to you know
support
children who are born in such
circumstances or
mothers who are in a predicament of
having to suddenly raise a child that
they didn't really want to raise no
because the people that are in favor of
these kinds of anti-choice measures also
are anti-welfare state stuff so you're
never going to see that you're never
going to concern ends with birth yeah
and
um
it's interesting like there could be
some weird cases that come up do you see
that that woman who was in a carpool
lane pregnant and got pulled over by a
texas oh yeah you share that with me
trooper or something
and she said he's like where's this
where's the second person she pointed at
her belly and basically she now has a
line because she was using that same
legal argument which is that personhood
of of the fetus and so she technically
could get out of it on person she was in
the hov lane right the carpool lane yeah
so you know pregnant the cop was not
either this is a person in my belly or
it's not right if it's not then then
that offends the entire argument right
right right so that kind of stuff could
happen um i like malcolm
bringing back to malcolm his take on
this is basically that we have this the
supreme court is um unchecked they have
too long a life um you need term limits
uh ezra klein had an 18-year term limit
suggestion in his article which is what
gave rise to malcolm writing about this
in his newsletter omg which is i i
recommend it it's a fun read oh h
mg yeah and it's always a quick and fun
read and and educational this one is
he thinks that every year the longest
tenured judge should have to retire or i
guess wouldn't be called retired be
stand down and then whoever's whatever
president is is in power can appoint the
next and the senate same kind of
structure to a point but then that gives
a nine-year term limit basically by
definition which in his mind is you know
it it it
offers that kind of depolarization
they're not necessarily a creature of
the political cycle because this idea
that they are removed from the political
cycle now is obviously [ __ ] we've
seen it now right so malcolm goes
through like the multiple times
throughout the majority opinion that
they make clear that they're not
you know beholden to political interests
and it's sort of a he death protest too
much type of thing like yes
so
it's hard to imagine
um
a counter argument to that like the
wisdom of term limits seems to make
sense well the arcana argument is it was
in the constitution i mean that's all
that right everyone wants to say let's
come on
i mean
the idea i just i can't stand this idea
that we're we're trying to read the
minds of people who lived in a world
that looks nothing like ours
and people who couldn't conceive of what
you know type of problems we would face
and the complexity of the culture as it
exists today and i think certainly we
can extract principles and tenets that
hold true
that provide you know kind of the
architecture of the constitution
but but when we get into
strict constructionist mind reading i
think we're really having to do some
crazy gymnastics in order for you know
our agenda to kind of fit
what these people might or might not
have imagined
and that applies to second amendment
issues etc and all the way down the line
you know what rich those are fighting
words and i'm gonna go get my musket
i'll be right back right i mean when the
14th amendment was passed are you
supposed to think about what they were
thinking in
1780 whatever or at the time that the
14th amendment was passed there were
more liberal people in 1480. i'm sure we
could find more liberal people
[Laughter]
the people who were setting up house in
jamestown were some serious wackos
that's the whole point like this country
this idea that we've regressed though is
funny we have regress but it's like it's
not like this stuff wasn't handwriting
on the wall like the people the puritans
who came to massachusetts were kicked
out of england because they were making
everyone stop drinking and having fun
and like burning down the globe theater
it's like nobody wanted them there
anymore and so then they came to boston
that's the truth i know it's pretty
funny when you think of it that way yeah
yeah yeah that's the truth ah well you
mentioned digi digable digable planets
yes
that's that's a good you know uh natural
segue as my other segway into uh the web
telescope images i love it what did you
make of all this man i loved it i loved
seeing those photos um i'm a big karina
nebula guy now by the way we i think we
went for like
18 minutes on the abortion right go
ahead it's because yeah that's probably
my fault everyone's gonna blame me
anyway all your political opinions get
blamed on me
there might be a little bit of that
i get i get a fair amount of blame
listen you can't talk about that subject
matter without people getting upset
right and we're supposed to be able to
be grown-ups um this was great you know
i loved the um
the i think is it shannon steron the uh
the opinion piece um
the tell the about the extraordinary
images i love that piece
right here shocking and awe at the
universe together yeah she wrote that um
you know this is like one of those
things where we can yeah it's like a
public
we're all together watching this thing
and it's a good thing and it's a
positive thing and how rare are those i
mean that's why i love writing stories
about um people pushing human limits and
successful ones at that
because they are they are good inspiring
stories and we need those so this is
another one of those and the images are
just tremendous and spectacular and like
it just shows you how
how glorious the world is
and the universe is
is this the one thing we can all agree
on
are there are there debates going on
right now divisive debates about this i
don't think it does feel pretty unifying
like if if this can't unify us i i
really i don't know think about it it's
like a collaboration among nasa european
space agency canadian space agency i
mean that like nasa like the
international space station is often
um
uh
you know held down by russia we were
sending people for like american
astronauts from russia like the space
area
is the one place we can all agree on and
elon will find life in outer space he
will
yeah if he can get out of this twitter
contract we'll see about whether he can
he's trying hard
but lawsuits are afoot
they might hold his hand to the flame
this time i think that'll end up
settling how did this land for you you
were deep in second coven when this was
going on i was yeah i mean listen it's
hard to it's hard to
you know look at those images and not
just be inspired with awe and wonder and
humility the thing that really got me
um was the
the paragraph um i think it's on the
nasa site where
they say for a sense of scale like if
you take that main image yeah like you
can see it on the screen right there the
one that got shared first shannon wrote
this one you're talking about yeah oh
yeah for a sense if you could hold a
grain of sand at arm's length up to the
sky
that speck is the size of the view in
other words everything that you see in
that image which is so much
can be held in that grain of sand and
then there's everything else so it's it
is one minuscule sliver of our universe
filled with thousands of galaxies each
with billions of trillions of star
systems and each of those with its own
planets i mean
it's so hard to you can read that and
you can try to intellectualize it but
the numbers are so big yeah that you
can't grasp it and it's only in seeing
an image like that that's so crisp and
detailed that you can begin to kind of
grapple with
the vastness of scale and i don't know
you know i look at that and i just think
there's no way we're alone like how
could it be possible that we're alone
where's dune which one's doomed
you mean the sand dune in malibu
which one's dude where's the spice
and the worms where's the where's the
worm planet
and then that's not even getting into
the fact that like you're looking back
in time right yeah like so our brains
aren't we can't understand that what
that means
oh what you're seeing is that's billions
of years ago yeah and it's far away
but it's it's it's you know it just it
like that's why you said you said that
when you were feeling depressed like
uh feeling insignificant or whatever
um that's what i mean by it like that's
that's the
that's where feeling insignificant is a
positive thing right like the humility
aspect of it but also just the fact that
you're
you are just this one note in a concerto
and it's like it's a beautiful thing to
think of yourself that way it's freeing
it's it's liberating i don't find that
depressing at all i find that to be you
know calming yeah
and like your problems are are smaller
than that grain of sand because you're a
grain of sand so nobody really cares why
are you caring so much you know like and
that's not to say to not take your life
seriously or not take yourself seriously
or or um contend with your with your own
issues i think you should but but the
stakes we often put upon ourselves and
the pressure is so high and it doesn't
have to always be that way you know what
i say adam what i say cory booker look
out because adam skolnik is coming for
coming for your crown
your inspirational self-help guru crown
what
no yeah no you just delivered an awesome
monologue
i delivered a round of applause about it
i opened a can of richard
i opened a can of rich rolls there's
your reel for instagram
see if i can get camiola to cut it i
love the i love these web images i mean
it's it's really
just absolutely stunning
cool and uh
yeah man it's cool it's cool that we
live in a time where stuff like this is
coming out
you know what i i stumbled upon i was at
the uh
not the what's the anna what's the
what's the uh
museum down in uh in westwood
i mean uh
westwood that's the camera just there
the hammer yeah this is a barbara kruger
exhibit there right now yeah there's
something going on and there's like a
moon thing
we were that this i just went stopped
into the gift shop i love a museum gift
shop who doesn't love a museum gift shop
the best gift shops the best gift shops
there's always some kind of weird clock
you know they're always trying to
reinvent the clock
when the clocks are completely useless
now
uh
but
uh i picked up this cool uh book i'll
show it to you but it's it's it's
basically all these from from all the
apollo uh expeditions all the apollo
missions
the photographs taken by the astronauts
themselves
and and then edited in a certain way and
with like kind of excerpts and and
writings from
eb white who was covering the apollo
missions for the new yorker at the time
he's got he's got one essay in there and
then there's other writings um but it's
just so cool to see these images of the
moon like a moon rock in the moon desert
you know the earth rising above the moon
and it just makes me feel you know feel
so good and watching when zuma looks up
at the moon it's like the greatest thing
in the world right you know it's that
simple simple stuff so like something
about space just still hits us i love it
hard yeah i mean you know as as we
talked about earlier i grew up in the
washington dc area
in bethesda which is the suburb of
washington
um and i still remember when the the air
and space museum opened and what a big
deal that was and how cool it was to go
there and at that time there was no the
sub the subway didn't reach all the way
out to bethesda
um but when it finally did
then i could take
the subway as like a young person and go
to the air and space museum with my
friend like as young people like without
parents and i used to go there like all
the time like i have that
museum like imprinted in my long-term
memory i just loved it so much yeah a
little rich roll rolling rocking i love
dancing they had a star trek exhibit and
like you know the the lunar lander and
the spirit of st louis
the original uh eems film powers of ten
yeah you know that movie where yeah yeah
yeah like i just oh man it was very
influential on me as a young person
still my favorite museum
let's just go be astronauts huh let's
just leave this behind
are you into
are you into uh for all mankind on apple
plus tv which one is that is that the
one where it's the one where they go
it's the alternate universe where the
russians win the space race and then
kind of what happens as a result of that
so no it's by ronald moore the guy who
created battlestar galactica no
and i think they're on season three now
it's a pretty cool show if you're
interested in i have not i've not seen
that i did just re-watch point break
have you heard of that film i have it's
a great film
body short for bodhisattva
um
and i i watched that does it hold up
it's so good dude
it's so good yet not good but that's
that's what makes it good yeah
all i can say is i'm going to watch
everything anthony keatis is in from now
on i forgot how great how many movies
i love him he's probably in a bunch of
movies and cameos i'm going to start
watching him that's funny nobody he he's
he he gets he gets shot in it he's so
good
he's perfect he's house keanu
listen man
i love keanu don't don't come at my guy
don't come in unless you have positive
things i love keanu reeves i also think
patrick swayze put on an epic
performance he's amazing underrated
master yes of the cinematic arts yes i
heard a rumor that he got so into
skydiving that that exit is actually his
exit he um he did like he got super into
it during the filming and did a lot of
it and like he's literally skydiving
himself doing stunts so that's pretty
cool
maybe we should do a whole episode
breakdown of point break i was wondering
did re-watchables do point break they
had to have they had that's a good
question
if they haven't it would be shocking if
they haven't
not recently maybe way back in the
archive i can't imagine they have it i
mean that's right up bill simmons alley
but that end when when keanu uh is
satisfied that that he's going to get
bodhi or bodhi will get got by the a
huge swell at bell's beach and he just
tosses his fbi uh badge aside into the
shallows and he's like i'm done with
this [ __ ] i was thinking
in real life you keep that badge until
you get to us customs you get through
customs only then do you toss because
there's no remember keep in mind this is
a long time ago there's no not 11. yeah
it's pre-911 so there and there's no
what's it called the global global entry
no global entry so you have to wait in
that line
trust me you hold on to that back until
you get it
one phone call
don't overthink it it's not keanu it's
an fbi agent right it's it's it's what's
his name
all right we're done talking about that
okay sorry but i do want to share one
thing that i've really enjoyed
i binged this entire series while i was
laying in bed with kovid um which is the
bear on fx yes
you've watched have you watched the
whole all the time seven out of eight
done seven out of eight we're shaking
the finales tonight is so [ __ ] good
it's my favorite new thing it's good and
each episode is only is under 30 minutes
right you can there's i think there's
eight episodes i don't get commercials
anymore
yeah you we were talking about this the
other night you're like i hate the
commercials on hulu i thought what are
you doing dude i thought everyone got
confused no
you got that goggins cash you can pay
six bucks a month or whatever it is 10
bucks a month
at least for a limited time you can
cancel it later yes yes yes yes
i love the bear bear is the story of uh
uh
this this young chef
who goes to new york
chefs that you know under the greatest
chef at the best restaurant in the world
yeah it it it would appear that he was a
sous chef at noma they talk about
nominations
chef cuisine just below executive show
right yeah um there's cameos by the way
of the noma cookbook and the
um noma fermentation book which was
written by david zilber who's somebody
that i've had the opportunity to meet
and i've been to noma uh i love how they
kind of make fun of eleven madison park
too yes but basically it's the story of
this guy who was really on this
trajectory towards chef super stardom he
was one of the best best yeah he wanted
james beard award food and wine's best
young new chef or something and his
older brother dies his brother had a
history with addiction and he moves home
to chicago
and takes over the family-owned sandwich
shop he kills himself the older brother
i think right yeah commits suicide yeah
and he takes it upon himself to
try to get this capsized enterprise back
on its feet and perhaps even do
something interesting there
and it's sort of a comedy it's sort of a
drama the performances are are
just off the charts jeremy allen white
as the chef evan moss baccarat as like
they call him a cousin i think he's just
like a friend who works there he's kind
of a hot head he was like the best
friend yeah yeah yeah yeah
of the of the older brother yeah and
then he had been running things in the
absence
like after it happened so he he stayed
in charge of basically and the chef came
in and started ruffling his feathers
basically right and just crushes the
chicago accent and he's you had said
he's like shades of a young gary old man
from state of grace i think so exactly
not not as maniacal as that because he's
not a killer but he's uh but certainly
flying off the opera the operatic he has
the juicy part oh yeah you know i mean
it just absolutely crushes it amazing um
people would know him from girls if you
watch that show he had a part in girls
he's a phenomenon oliver platt's brother
or oliver platt is is uh has a great
part in this as well what's interesting
is that oliver platt's brother adam
platt
was uh he just retired but he was a food
critic for many many years he was the
chief
food critic for new york magazine and
when i went to noma with jeff gordanier
i was also with adam platt oh okay it's
cool that like adam's brother oliver is
in the show which is about food
um yeah oliver platt's never been better
in my opinion he's fantastic than this
yeah so i love everything about this
show
uh particularly episode seven
we don't need to get it i want people to
experience this show without uh spoiling
anything but episode seven just bear in
mind the entire episode is one shot uh
it's a tracking shot for all of 28
minutes or something like this
unbelievable cinematic achievement
and the tension the humor the pathos
like everything about this is just
wonderful and exactly what you would
want from
the best of what television has to offer
what about uh the fact that it's like i
mean for your enough for your listeners
whatever but it's all about it's
basically a french dip restaurant right
like that's it's like it's like a steak
it's like a it's like a roast beef
sandwich and hot dog joint yeah i mean
it's a classic hole-in-the-wall
family-owned you know sandwich shop so
neighborhood sandwich shop in chicago
right do those seared beef uh images
actually make you kind of like do you
know how they're shot in a way to make
you passed it i'm over it you're past
that yeah not even but i've had listen
i've spent my fair share of time in
spots like that particularly like phil
you're like you go out drinking you're
in buffalo yeah you're in philly yeah
you want that cheese steak late night
yeah like this is where you go
so here's my one critique of the show
uh-oh
why is it only open from three to ten
there is a weird thing about that like
it's a sandwich shop like philippe's
downtown is open at like 9am or 7am or
something like that it does seem that
they don't open until like three o'clock
or something but at three they go three
to ten
but
is it possible that they have an earlier
shift and then they close and they'll
reopen
there is there is something there is
something weird about hours and it says
this whole time for the first time i
understand the late night but they're
not open to like two in the morning
either so that's my whole thing i was
they missed lunch
and who wants a sandwich for dinner
that's my point and then they're not
open when the bar's gone no wonder
they're struggling
that's what i was saying this whole time
i was i was saying
to april i'm like but when do they open
i i couldn't figure it out and she was
like
and she couldn't figure it out we
couldn't and so and now it's they're
opening three to ten sorry spoiler alert
they're open three to two there it is um
you know it's been a great time for me
to watch it pull up that page i just put
up so people can see who have not heard
of this show yes um anyway i love it we
can overlook that i do overlook it i'm
just joking but i i love the fact that
i've also been on a uh anthony bourdain
deep dive and so i just read kitchen
kitchen confidential which
so interesting because it it there's the
parallels with the chef and the whole
with the chefing and even the suicide
angle and all that and the and and the
misanthropic kind of undertones of it
intensity and the intensity and the the
collegiality like the family aspect and
the machismo of a kitchen and all that
like because that's that's deep in in in
the kitchen confidential and which is a
if you have only watched the television
shows and you'd like anthony bourdain i
highly recommend you you'll love that
yeah it's it's and you'll love the bear
yeah and and anyway so just having
watched that uh at the time that i'm
reading that book has been kind of fun
you know feedback and they just got
renewed for a second season of course i
mean come on yeah
the performances in this show are
fantastic i think it's it almost
especially the first episode and episode
seven both of those where there's so
much of the entire cast in it all at
once in a tight confined
space and talking over each other it's
almost like a play yeah it's very
theatrical yeah yeah and i think a lot
of these actors come from the theater
right
uh anyway i love it
i come from the highly recommended
do you yeah i just was at the theater of
downstream the theater of the demented
mind thank you all right let's do some
listener questions we haven't done these
in a long time what listeners they got
interrupted by cory booker yeah sorry
guys
this is anna grace from
charlottesville virginia
hi rich and adam i'm anna grace i'm from
charleston virginia and i'm going into
my fourth year of college here
i know that i want to do public service
work in the international affairs area a
lot of your interview guests talk about
the importance of prioritizing your own
well-being and living a holistic life
that isn't overly focused on gaining
accolades or a narrow definition of
success however it seems like a lot of
them did have a very work and accolade
centric beginning of their career and
this is definitely something i feel a
lot of pressure to do because the jobs
where i feel that i can ultimately have
the most impact kind of require it
do you think that having a sort of very
unbalanced and maybe unhealthy focus on
work is a rite of passage to launch
yourself into a position of impact
or is there a better way to think about
this for young people specifically i'm
curious to hear your thoughts i really
admire you both and thank you for all of
the work that you do thank you
first of all
anna grace
great name
very good name right great question and
great name
and i love the delivery the delivery was
fabulous all i'm thinking like i barely
heard what she said other than this
thought that kept recurring in my mind
which is adam can you imagine being in
your fourth year of college
and
thinking about things in the way that
anna is thinking about them in such a
mature way
no because i would be uh like dropping
acid or smoking
a bong rip
yeah i mean first of all like
whatever i say
almost doesn't matter anna because like
you're gonna be fine if this is where
your head's at and you're kind of
weighing these things in this way you're
already like miles down the road like
you'll be fine
right yeah i mean i i'll figure it out i
i think i think it's an incredible
question because i don't you're right i
don't think people 10 years 15 years
older than her think like think things
things through so just the fact that
you're asking yourself this question and
trying to figure it out puts you in rare
companies yeah so let me just say that
to begin with
um and then second of that
i think it's worth
noting that you should be congratulated
on having some conviction about what you
want to do and and how you want to do it
and a sense of how to go about it in a
healthy way like again speaks to your
maturity and intelligence and
you know i think
the way that i would launch into
answering this is to first sort of
acknowledge your youth i mean i assume
as somebody who's in their fourth year
of college you're in your early 20s
and and i think of that time as a time
for exploration
for gathering experiences all kinds of
different experiences and a time where
it makes sense to incur some risk right
like you don't have a mortgage you don't
have family you don't have dependents
it's a time in your life where you will
be as free as you ever will be
to try lots of things uh without you
know
without having to really you know suffer
any
amazing consequences like this is the
time for that and i think in the context
of what you want to pursue which is
public service in international affairs
what's interesting about that is that it
is it is both specific and broad like
it's specific in that like it's a kind
of a thing in a certain type of area
that you seem to
be attracted to
wherein there is probably a very
specific path for moving upward but it's
also pretty broad and i think when you
say international affairs like that
could be anything and as somebody in
your 20s i immediately leaped to like
we'll travel like immerse yourself in
foreign cultures be an international
citizen and i think long term even
though that doesn't seem
specifically wed to a particular career
track it will be extremely valuable as
you progress in that world in terms of
what you have to have to offer so again
think about how you can accumulate
experience
in that field from that broad
perspective because within it i suspect
i suspect that there are many jobs in
paths probably most of which you
may not even be aware of at this
juncture
on the work hard thing
that's a really interesting wrinkle to
all of this because it is important to
work hard right like
you cannot excel
or
you know kind of
accelerate yourself into a lofty
position without working hard i think
the key
is being aware of your attachment to
specific jobs and to specific outcomes
and to learn how to hold those loosely
to work hard and focus on the things
that you can control but to not get
irrationally attached to any specific
job or track
or externalities like accolades etc
and again you know back to this idea of
international affairs i mean that seems
to me to be something that could be
anything it could be self-dictated and
right now
my advice would be that your job
should really be a bit a be about
becoming internationally educated again
back to travel and experience and
not getting caught up in externalities
and and to focus on like what excites
you what lights you up in the field of
international affairs and to try lots of
things and
develop expertise in a variety of areas
allah david epstein and his book range
which if you if you have not read that
book you should certainly read it and i
think over time all of those experiences
will like sort of congeal and come into
play
uh to uniquely situate you for the role
that you ultimately want to play and and
might position you to be
the only person in the world suitable
for that specific thing because of the
unique set of experiences that that
you've had
and i think within that it's important
you know as a young person coming out of
college there's a sense of expediency
like i gotta i gotta move forward i
gotta climb the ladder i'm missing out
people are getting ahead of me
and i think you should really
just embrace the idea that you're at the
beginning of a very long journey and
within that you can kind of relax and
prioritize self-care as important and
valuable but not to confuse that with
laziness because you will have to work
hard
but i think that hard work should come
within the context of a strategy
uh that relates to playing the long game
like you can work hard
and you can take care of yourself
they're not necessarily mutually
exclusive or orthogonal ideas and i
think that's a mistake i see a lot of
young people make like they rationalize
laziness as self-care or as an excuse to
not work hard because to be successful
you're gonna have to work hard yes uh
but ultimate success means avoiding
burnout and designing a life that aligns
with your values over an extended period
of time so that you can continue
to get better at what it is that you do
without burning out or without suffering
the negative ramifications of like an
unhealthy work schedule and i think now
is the best time to
get clear on what that might look like
and lay the foundation for that
100
i uh that's so well done you do these so
well these listener questions how can i
say i did make notes can i say that
um
i'm getting shades of samantha power and
anna grace you know what i'm saying
samantha power the obama ambassador to
the u.n i believe
and she wrote a book called the
education of an idealist
and i heard her on i think it was on uh
terry gross or something and she's
phenomenal i wonder if if anna has read
that um
listen i i'm someone who decided i
wanted to write my way around the world
and i did that um and i was able to do
that because i i really did was
single-minded in that pursuit that
doesn't mean i was the most always the
most work obsessed but by the time i
started doing it for a living it did
demand
months at a time with no days off so
that kind of stuff does happen and you
have short deadlines and you have to
meet them and and and um
and so there are time there's time and
place for that kind of single-minded
pursuit and i think the idea of doing
that young
when you don't have the kind of the the
baggage that comes with um
you know just being older and being more
established you you know you're you're
you're sleek you can move around so i
think and you can make it fun yeah you
can make it you can bust your ass and if
it is really what you love doing it
there should be a significant aspect of
it it's going to be exhilarating it's
going to bring you joy but also you're
going to have to you've got to learn
that with when that's the case you're
even more in a danger zone because then
you'll never take a break well so right
and and you don't want to get to that
point but i think the great part about
international life is that you're always
it's always something's always happening
it's pretty sick and it's like jason
bourne yeah it's pretty awesome and
you're going to work hard and then
you're there's going to be opportunities
to hang out and have fun and explore
different places because it's all you're
international i think the best piece of
advice you gave is be international and
that means
learning languages
that you know you need you want to be
bilingual
learning language yeah experiencing
those cultures boots on the ground and
understanding their politics and their
history 100
and and that's the greatest piece of
advice you gave and i think that i would
i would say that like just go
get lost go go to go to wherever you
want to go and explore it and be part of
it and um
and you will not go wrong whatever comes
out of that the other thing is
you know it's funny how
when you have this idea that you want to
do or be something then you kind of get
there
and then you realize how limiting that
was
and something else comes up so like for
me wanting to write my way around the
world then after doing lonely planet
book after like basically doing that for
seven eight years that's all i did
um i realized well that wasn't really
the pinnacle of the craft of writing and
so i had other
ambitions that kind of came up that's
part of growth right so that's going to
happen so that idea of holding things
lightly it's not just because hey it may
not work out it's actually because hey
you might evolve and your ambitions will
evolve with you and therefore you know
it's okay to hold certain
uh
destinations lightly in terms of you
know career destinations because
things could change for you too
so that the idea that this is just an
experience to to to get the most out of
and to dedicate yourself to it whether
it's uh you know working 60 hours a week
or not um
i like that attitude i see i see success
in anna grace's future like i said i'm
not worried about i'm not worried about
anna no she's gonna be fine i'm jealous
sounds like she's getting ready for an
awesome life
it's true you want to go back in time
yeah you might be rich
growing up in the greater washington dc
area i was i was in a perfect position
to become a spy an international spy
i had a friend i had a friend i had a
friend whose dad was a cia that's
exactly what an international spy would
say what you just said
yes
i would be so good as a spy
that's what really has been happening
all right let's move on let's move to
dan from silver spring dan from silver
spring 301 silver spring get it back to
dc
listener you think
you think this is dan from silver spring
with a question but really it's a
message for his support right this is my
handler my handler at langley
he lives in silver spring he works in
lagging commute see camilla okay all
right
hey rich and adam this is dan from
silver spring just outside dc
twitch thanks for your passion i'll be
six years sober september and your show
helps me stay on the path but i wanted
to call today to ask both of you about
gratitude you both talk about how
important it is in your lives as many of
your guests have as well most notably
tommy ribs who's a personal hero of mine
as well
i have a lot to be grateful for sobriety
a loving wife who is my best friend two
kids who are hilarious and awesome for
health
i had a brain tumor removed a few years
ago and i'm back and running and hiking
just like before so there's a lot there
i'm having trouble grasping this idea
though
every time i think about all of the
things i have to be grateful for it's
kind of like yeah okay things are good
cool
how do you guys embody gratitude what am
i missing here and how do people like
you and adam and tommy ribs live that
gratitude thanks so much guys peace
i feel like that last sentence there is
the cipher
yeah the radio that will unlock the
radio how we decode the rest of this
message the radio that shows yeah that
shows who he really is and dropping all
these key words right yeah
tommy rivs gratitude
[Music]
what's gratitude really found out yeah
i've been discovered
anyway uh this is a really good question
dan thank you for that and uh i
appreciate you sharing that story and
obviously you've gone through some
really hard stuff and must have been
really
challenging to endure all of that and
you're on the other side of it and
you're asking yourself the right
question right like how can i connect
more deeply with gratitude my sense just
from your tone of voice and the way that
you kind of laid this question out
is it is that and i could be totally
wrong but it sounds like you're kind of
living in your head and trying to
intellectualize this idea of gratitude
and perhaps that's
serving to block you from just
emotionally connecting with it because
it's like this equation you're trying to
solve with your mind as opposed to an
allowing or a letting go that will open
you up emotionally to this type of
experience which is hard to do and i'm
very
sympathetic and and and empathetic to
that like gratitude is tricky
i've talked about this a lot on the
podcast as i've said many times i don't
naturally exude it
i'm petty i'm competitive i'm super
jealous of adam i'm even more envious
about them yeah grouchy yeah i can be
i'll try to all true all true right yeah
uh and and gratitude
is just one modality a powerful modality
a practice
that can be deployed to keep those baser
emotions at bay and help you connect
with the things that are most important
and the tasks for cultivating it again
as i've discussed many times are
multivariate you could do a gratitude
list writing down every single day
before you go to bed or the minute you
wake up in the morning a list of 10
things that you're grateful for although
that can be an intellectual exercise and
it sounds like maybe you have even tried
that and it's not working and i get that
too
you can be of service to those in need
you can call up an old friend that you
haven't spoken to before and tell him
that you miss him or her you can write a
letter to somebody you care about in
other words practicing the expression of
gratitude aids in cultivating that
sense within yourself but
i really hear what you have to say dan
because
often in in doing this
myself i find that connecting with
gratitude is is difficult that it can be
this intellectual pursuit that doesn't
really
pay off emotionally and it's really a
struggle to figure out how to feel it
like feel it with your body
the way that i've been able to kind of
turn the page and and pull the covers on
that
is through mindfulness and meditation
because i think the more that you can be
present with yourself
and opt out of the looping patterns of
patterns of your brain and just be at
one with others the environment then the
more attuned you can become
to the emotional states that you're
experiencing and in particular in this
case gratitude and if you look at tommy
rivs
i think it's pretty clear
that he's somebody who is very
heart-centered like he lives in his
heart not in his head and and as such is
very adept
at being able to connect with gratitude
like myself on the other hand i have to
really practice
just to experience glimpses of it but i
do think it's possible and it does come
more easily with a consistent practice
it is a practice
of trying to strip away the
non-essentials from your awareness and
in your case i would say
you know the the intellectualization of
not just this experience but of probably
a lot of things in your life and trying
to move that awareness down into your
heart and then giving of yourself really
freely to other people with your
attention your time your empathy i think
that breaks the chain of self-obsession
that can come with intellectualizing or
over-intellectualizing things
and beyond that you know i don't know
what else to tell them
or tell you dan
um other than than that and to continue
to to pursue it because it is a
worthwhile investment of your time and
energy
yeah what do you think
i agree with you i think um
what's worked for me is just this
awareness of that the interconnectedness
of all things so
uh
you know that's why i love getting in
the ocean so often because to me that's
like the physical expression of inner
you're you're now in this other world
and
and
you're
kind of taken out of your own head
you have to be
um
and you're now just experiencing life
as opposed to analyzing it at the same
time so much of us all we're doing is
analyzing all the time you know we're
not really you have to you have to
interrupt that default state and i think
you know for you it's jumping in the
ocean i mean that works for me as well
you can look at those images from the
web telescope yeah for a lot of people
that in spot inspires that sense of awe
and 100 um but for other people they
could look at that and say that's cool
but i don't you know whatever so it's
it's a it's an individual thing and so i
guess what you're saying and what i
would suggest
um
is that uh dan
figure out the thing that does
you know provide him with a sense of awe
and wonder when was the last time that
he felt
like a heart-centered profound sense of
on wonder and try to figure out ways of
of
recapturing or or uh recapitulating that
experience in his life yeah and the
thing is you can't force it right it's
like it's like one of those things where
you know if you're on the hiking trails
sitting down and and breathing
to give yourself a chance to get there
is a good way of saying like like well
the breath the breath work
as well and meditation and just like
looking at cloud formations and just
kind of keeping it super simple
um is one way of doing it but at the
same time i also empathize because you
know when
you hear it all the time when you're a
father and your wife's about to give
birth and you hear like wait till you
see the baby there's going to be this
like emotional shocky pod payoff kind of
thing like where you realize ah and you
have this thing and i didn't expect that
to happen to me it did not happen to me
um but some of that comes from
expectation and and so this idea that
there is a place to get to to experience
it um can get in your way so i would be
self-critical when you're not
experiencing it yeah because listen
we're guys and we're not always
that in tune with our emotions that's
just the way it is speak for yourself i
mean you are very in tune with your
emotions um and i think i am too to a
point but like but and
so i'm with you dan i think it's not
always gonna be right there for us but i
also understand what rich is saying it's
it's a practice
and if it means you know every day
trying to connect with really basic
things not necessarily i'm great for my
wife i'm grateful for my kids i'm
grateful for where i live blah blah that
helps that's nice but even just as
simple as um
i'm grateful for for that sunset or
whatever eventually you might get that
that hit might come
and um and then then once it comes it
just grows once you once that practice
will just grow and um anyway that's all
i can say yeah does that make sense that
makes sense all right i'll stop talking
now let's go to kyle from massachusetts
hey rich and adam my name is kyle
stanley i'm from massachusetts and i'm a
long time listener of rich's podcast and
my question revolves around the fact
that i'm doing ryan holiday's read to
lead challenge currently which is a paid
course by ryan holliday where he teaches
you how to
read more efficiently and how reading
can help improve your life which i
believe myself
the challenge for this week is to ask
five people who you respect for a book
recommendation that changed their lives
so you two are people that have already
changed my life so my question for you
two is what is a book
in your life that has transformed or
changed the way that you view the world
or the way you act thank you kyle
message received
and i'm currently sending it to
my cipher colleague he's sending the
books he's sending the books
my answer to this is not that sexy uh
but
it's true for me um
the book that has changed my life the
most hands down is the big book of
alcoholics anonymous
i don't know if kyle needs to read that
book probably not no maybe he does
uh if i'm being completely honest like i
come with some sexy book obscure title
that would make me sound cool but
honestly it's the
big book changed my life more than any
other book and then second to that can
you describe the big book because i have
not it's basically you've never heard of
it no i'm sure you've seen it in various
starbucks with people sitting huddled
over it it's the bible of alcoholics
anonymous essentially which lays out the
12-step program and has stories of
people who have battled with and
overcome
alcoholism and it's sort of the
you know the guidebook and the
centerpiece to the whole kind of 12-step
architecture of
of alcoholics anonymous fair yeah
um so obviously that book changed my
life continues to change my life it's a
book that i'm my lit it's not like a
book i read and put down it's like an
operating role for life right uh this
the other operating manuals for life
that have been incredibly transformative
for me are also no surprise to anybody
who listens to this podcast the war of
art by steven pressfield absolutely has
been essential in
helping me you know craft this
my professional life and how i think
about and pursue creativity
second to that the artist's way by julia
cameron which is sort of a workbook
way of unleashing creativity and kind of
finding your voice
and a fourth if none of those satisfy
you
would be autobiography of a yogi by
paramahansa yogananda which will blow
your mind with
tales of spiritual prowess and magical
mystical possibilities
love it you've read that book haven't
you i have i have in fact i uh when i
was doing early on in the la yoga world
i was doing writing i always forget
about the la yoga chapter of your life
yeah
and one of the first epi like the first
features we did were kind of the history
of yoga in la and was so focused on the
1920s era which was palmer hansi
yogananda and i went to the
self-realization fellowship in mount
washington which was his real house
the og
and we were supposed to i was supposed
to meet and talk to this particular monk
uh in the conference room but i guess
that had been booked out and so he sat
me down
in uh in like by the fireplace and he
goes and he when we sit down he said you
know parma nazi yogananda used to spend
every evening here or yogi ji or
whatever you call them he's spent every
evening here talking to whoever guests
came by and it's said that sometimes
when you sit here and talk for a while
you can actually feel his presence when
you leave and i'm like yeah sure
and so then i sat and had my interview
with him and the guy was fine like i
didn't feel like you know you when
you're speaking to some people who have
like the spiritual connection you can
feel it i didn't feel anything special
but then when i left
it was like i was walking like i walked
out of the house all of a sudden i was
like walking on air like i felt so alive
and like
you know alive and high and
and uh and so i did have that feeling
there so that's interesting and that
that's saying a lot coming from you
being a natural-born skeptic
you know it's a recalcitrant
i'm a many layered lotus many peddled
lotus that's true but that that lotus is
just opening up it's just opening it up
with every roll-on episode this is my
mission adam well it's funny blossoming
and flowers it's funny you should say
that because my book the book i'm
thinking of is called hua hu ching it's
the unknown teachings of lao tzu it's a
follow up kind of like the lost scrolls
of the data chain
and i'm thinking of a moment it was uh
in i think in 1995 i was sitting on a
bluff in isla vista overlooking the
beach with my good friend and podcaster
kelton reed of the ryder files a guy who
i was a screenwriting partner with when
we were both trying to become writers
him right out of a boulder
uh university of colorado and myself
kind of trying to figure out what i
wanted to do
and we were working for this like grind
them to the bone uh environmental group
that we were out there kind of getting
members for the sierra club or whatever
summer canvassing like boots on the
ground campaign work
um and it was like the summer getting
ready for the big summer canvas season
and i came up late i was kind of bummed
out i've been burned out i've been
working for this organization for like
almost two years and i was like ground
to the bone of a lot of work hard work
and not feeling the reward and he sits
me there and i'm feeling like i i became
friends with them up in portland a few
few months before and he hands me this
book i didn't know him well at the time
he hands me this book and i read it and
i just get overwhelmed with that same
feeling i got at parma hansa yogananda
from from something reason this this
lightness in my body was almost like the
only thing i compared to is like a
psychedelic feeling like when it's
coming on but i hadn't taken anything i
didn't drink anything and it was
available to me and then for the next
week we just spent the week kind of
reading this book and on that beach
sleeping on that beach illegally and
just hanging out with a group of friends
for that week and that book taught me to
for the rest of that week i was focused
on positives everything that came at me
was i was misinterpreted i was taking it
apart and just bringing the positives to
my life and that's all i thought about
and that really was the beginning of me
seeing life as a quest
as a quest for myself versus as a life
to just
you do one thing then you do the other
thing all of a sudden life became a
quest i started getting into like the
esoteric carlo castaneda teachings of
don juan books you know and and getting
out into nature as much as possible and
feeling the power of nature and and that
kind of set me up for everything i think
i could give you a million books i like
better that you know amazing works of
literature um but that book more than
anything kind of that moment changed
everything for me
that's pretty powerful testimony
i feel inspired to read this book now
look at that who's making speeches on
rich i'm so inspired by you adam see
this lotus flower those petals are
opening up
and the power that is emanating forth
the vibration the audio vibration going
out into the universe look at you
see stepping into your own path you see
me as a skeptic yes i am a little bit
quest manifest yeah quest baby life is a
quest i like it man and you got through
that whole thing without dropping a
kerouac reference but you kind of there
was an intuitive kind of
reference to like an on the road kind of
vibe those guys were looking for
questing yeah the beat poets they were
the ones that know that's your shot
yeah they saw it as life but it comes
from modern life the origin of that is
yeah the deeper stuff yeah exactly and
then you know since then the doubt of
ching is kind of a daily companion and
we're almost daily so
i think that was a solid roll on hey
thanks man i think that works too yeah
how do you feel
what's the title of this episode digable
planets that's good that kind of brings
it all into one doesn't it yeah
um
let me just say you look great
thank you
are you i mean you look post covert even
better than before look at you it's cool
exuding gratitude
empathy
thinking about others i know look at you
what did you think i was
but if you cut me off i will revoke your
[ __ ] driver's license all right
starting with mathis
all right let's end it
we'll see you back here in a couple
weeks thanks for taking uh this crazy
rollercoaster ride with us hope you guys
had fun and uh we'll see you back here
soon
peace
plants
[Music]
you